one of the games you've found to be
pretty cool is the uh hakara Nakamura
versus gulfon in 2009 and that one I
think concludes the king's Indian
defense yes
um what's what's why is that an
interesting one to you
he'll play the Kings Indian as black and
I loved this model game but and as Alex
was saying like all these advantages for
the king's Indian but now there's this
one line that like every higher rated
player just destroys my King's Indian
and you see these beautiful games
they're like ah yes I want to play for
these ideas but now no one plays into it
anymore and you just get demolished so
this is why I don't put the kings in
dating anymore but not to ruin the
funner it's the love hate relationship
truly the reality but that's like the
higher level players do or does
everybody yeah if you're cutting
openings and you know this line as white
you just you automatically get the upper
Edge and that's kind of how openings
develop you start having players trying
new lines and then you see ones and then
everybody adopts it if they think it's
the best one but yeah so Hikaru is
really known for his aggressive style of
play Chicago black hero yeah Hikaru is
black here so he's playing the king's
Indian and as you can see in this
position white already has a lot a huge
Center Advantage but what Hikaru is
going to start doing even with the next
move is bringing all of his pieces
towards the white king side because his
plan is to start pushing his pawns
towards the white king and ignore the
attack
dream attack with the king's Indian so
there's a complete asymmetry towards the
king's side on the left side of the
board there's a ton of pieces yeah
exactly
um wow he moved the net like three times
in a row and that's what you need to do
because you have to move the knight in
order to make space for your Pawn so
again this is why it's so
counterintuitive and stockfish doesn't
like it you're putting almost most of
your pieces on the back Rank and you're
pushing your king side pawns and you're
blocking your own dark squared Bishop so
none of it makes sense you're mimicking
it that's awesome
um okay so yeah here you see
for a queen side attack black going for
the king side attack and you can keep
going a little bit and I'll wait to
where he starts with the pretty
sacrifices
it's more fun to analyze games in person
than on the computer I think yeah
let's just go okay so here Hikaru is
preparing the attack and what I really
like about this game is that he finds
these tactics that are not necessarily
what a computer would go for but it's
very hard to face as a human and that's
why a lot of people play The King's
Indian because in in practice it's hard
to defend against so we can keep moving
a little bit forward
okay
yep so white is just continuing the king
side plan and now it's the first is that
like the first piece I think that's
taken in the game yep that's the first
trade so this begins exactly Hikaru had
to pause his attack for a little bit to
just make sure that white didn't have
two dire threats on the queen side it's
so cool to see the asymmetry of this
thing exactly that's what's beautiful
about this and just one thing to
highlight because his his Rook move here
is very bizarre and typically like a
computer probably didn't like this but
the ideas are very interesting because
this is a major weakness for black that
they're coming to attack and he's also
making room for his Bishop to come
backwards and challenge so this is like
a human-like maneuver that computer I
think computers would like this though
because you have to you'd have to move
it regardless because he has he takes
the pawn here and his rule could be
under attack yeah well have you looked
at it when I actually studied this as a
line and this right away isn't the best
move according computer so actually
that's a good question so do you guys
when you study games use your own mind
but do you also use computers to build
up your into version of like looking at
a position like this and what would a
computer do and then try to understand
why it wants to do that when I was
studying seriously I would try to use my
own mind because you're never going to
get the exact same position so you
really need to notice Trends and often
computers will give you moves that are
only specific to that position because
of a certain tactic but I do use
computers to check what I did and make
sure I didn't make any obvious blender
that I might have missed what does a
computer tell you just like what is the
best move or does it give you any kind
of explanation of why it does doesn't
tell you why but it gives you the
different valuations of the position
like black is down a half Pawn here or
something like that
um but it hints you towards what the
right move is and then it's on you to
figure out why and you could usually
figure out why if not right away than
just by going through a few moves and
being like oh okay that makes sense I
feel like a computer will take you down
with some weird lines potentially like
sacrifice like why the hell am I
sacrificing this well we'll get to the
pretty sacrifice soon
um so we could just keep playing the
bonds are being pushed forward yeah
and Hikaru is kind of ignoring the queen
side attack here
um they basically both only reply to
each other's plan when they have to
this is where you convert all the
podcast viewers to YouTube yeah there
you have idea of what we're talking
about right now there is a Zen like
experience of just like listening and
Imagining the board just imagine the
pieces on the ceiling yeah you should we
should be calling them out and then
people would be freaking out even more
am I supposed to keep track of what the
position is
um
well it's too many how hard is blindfold
Jess have you tried like are you able to
keep them I've played blindfold trust
before
um for me it's pretty hard it's not a
muscle that I've trained as much and I'm
very visual when it comes to chess
um but it is one as a top player that
starts becoming very second nature for
you actually this is what I talked to
Magnus about this
um maybe I was again influenced by
Queen's Gamba what do you actually
visualize when it's in your head
so for Magnus it was a boring 2D board
right are you do you have some kind of
that's every chest player no you don't
have like because you know some chess
like uh computer games you can do all
kinds of skins and like yeah like fancy
stuff you don't have anything exactly I
don't have like a cool 3D Warrior mode
on it's just like a space board in my
head because you don't yeah you can't
use your brain power for adding colors
to it because you already have to keep
track of the pieces that's one board at
a time yes okay the current position
yeah I bet every chest I wonder if
there's any who there's certain players
who are really good and they can even
play blindfold chess and play multiple
games at the same time
um so I would be curious how they do it
but usually when you're thinking of one
game that's the only one in your mind
yeah but you have to do this operation
where you move one piece
you're doing like the branch analysis
like yeah and so uh you still have to
somehow visualize the the branching
process
um and not forget stuff maybe that's
like constant memory recall or something
you're always looking at one board at a
time but and you're also oh because
you're also looking in the future yeah
yeah and then you have to backtrack I
guess you're keeping the position in
your memory so you're remembering where
all the pieces are and then you're
playing it out on one board and then you
can come back to the initial one that
you started with that you kind of just
keep in your brain and it's also easier
to come back to it once you've played a
position from it I feel like it's that
memory recall
that gets you to blunder so I'll like
see that I'm being attacked by certain
things
but then because I get so exhausted
thinking about a different thing I
forget I actually forget about an entire
branch of things that I was supposed to
be worried about it happens very often
yeah if you spend a bunch of time
calculating in a position say like when
you're really in trouble and you're
spending 15 20 minutes calculating
you'll forget about something that you
spotted like oh if I do these two three
moves I'll walk into a trap because
you've looked at so many lines and then
you play it and then you see it and
you're like oh I I looked at it and I
saw it but I forgot about it yeah it's
often called tunneling where you're just
looking so deeply on one thing you
forget about the rest of the board
and it's the worst one at least in a
beginner level there's like a
I don't know Bishop just sitting there
obviously attacking your like queen or
something and then you just forget that
Bishop exists because if they just sit
there for a few moves and don't move you
just forget their existence and then
it's just yeah that's that's definitely
very embarrassing well it happens to
everyone so yes
um okay cool okay so
we see a few trades happening on the
queen side where he had to go for those
otherwise he's in trouble
um and this is where the game oh sorry
this is where it gets exciting yeah so
so Knight H4 is really when the
sacrifice starts and here the two
important pawns are the ones in front of
the king because they're helping with
the entire defense and Hikaru is
actually preparing to sacrifice his
Knight for a pawn
um just so that he can continue his
attack and open up the position because
if you don't do that here as black and
don't get some kind of attack you are
completely lost on The Queen side and
also you've pushed all of your own
kingside pawns so you're gonna be in
danger so it's one of those Do or Die
moments oh okay so that that's what
makes it all in because the king is wide
open yeah yeah the king is wide open and
you all of White's pieces are pointed
towards the queen side too where you're
also cramped so is the attack primarily
by black done by the two Pawns in the in
the night and the light squared Bishop
is always extremely important so you you
don't want to trade this in the king's
Indian because it's very helpful for a
lot of attacks
even though it's on the other side of
the board I guess it can go all the way
across in and like I don't I'm not sure
what it's doing here but probably
threatening like for example if if it
was another move black could have played
would be something like Bishop H3 where
if you take the bishop you actually get
mated on G2
with what so let's say you take here and
then you could push the pawn and then it
would be Checkmate so you're kind of
using your Bishop to sacrifice
against White's kingside pawns yeah I'll
be freaking out if they're Bishop did
that exactly what are they up to right
and that's the thing this position looks
very scary as white because all of
Black's pawns are starting to come
towards you and it's one of those things
where humans do start to worry in these
positions whereas computers obviously
can just calculate the best line and
maybe the attack doesn't go through so
you're saying a computer might say that
the white is actually a slight favorite
here yeah essentially exactly okay so
then uh White makes a little bit of room
by moving The Rook right and the attack
begins I like I like the commentary
then the night
um the night is hugging the king and
actually white can't even take the king
here because then H4 and H3 is coming in
and take the Knight yeah oh did I say
King yes thank you the night well I
can't take the Knight because why
um so if white takes the Knight here
then black starts pushing his Pawn to H4
with H3 incoming and the idea of trying
to defend against this is it looks very
difficult so why just choose it it'd be
cool to watch a chess game to experience
watching it without understanding it
just for a day I feel like I could use
that to make better content true
um okay I mean that's what getting drunk
does
originally for chess players it never
leaves it doesn't matter how but this is
actually a very cute move because
Black's Queen is under attack but the
king is so cramped that he can't
actually take it or he's gonna get
checkmated by a pawn which is a sad way
to go truly yeah those pawns are doing a
lot of work here
yeah these pawns are like uh right so
they're the ones that are doing a lot of
the threatening right and they're also
opening up the position to bring more of
the pieces in but that the the pawns
kind of help break open the king side
but they can't Checkmate by themselves
so after the pawns come in that's when
you need to start bringing in pieces as
well which you will see uh Hikaru do
here okay there you go he puts more
sacrifice so this was actually another
beautiful sacrifice in the game
um but then puts the king in check with
a pawn right that and the pawn is going
to be given here for free but the idea
is you're giving your own piece because
you want to have more space and open up
the King which is what you're always
trying to do when you have a king side
you're trying to remove as many of the
king's Defenders as you can without
giving up too much and then you have a
ton of pieces on the king side for black
just waiting to exactly to do harm and
then uh and notice how every single move
white is getting attacked like they're
just never getting a break black just
keeps throwing all their so it's funny
that Black's Queen has been hanging for
like three moves now and white still
can't do anything about it yeah so Rogue
puts the king in check yep the king runs
and then again we leave the queen
hanging and you develop a piece the
slight squared Bishop that's so
important and you're once again
threatening Checkmate on G2
and then Bishop's coming to yeah once
again the queen hanging I think and I
mean the game is just so beautiful the
amount of
calculation Hikaru put into this
position it feels like so much is in
danger right it's so interesting
and uh Knight takes what our pawns so
now his Queen is attacked twice and he
doesn't care he takes the bishop and
he's still threatening the Checkmate on
G2
and then uh the queen takes the bishop
so now he's defending against you too
and black just goes and grabs some
material back here so here black is
already is winning well he ends up
winning a knight here because black had
to be so much on the defensive
they're just taking pieces yeah I mean
at this point you're up two whole pieces
so yeah exactly but
and queen queen
and then you take
and then the Rook takes
and there's not as much of an attack on
the king anymore but Hikaru is up a
night here which is GG yeah what's the
correct way of of of saying that because
I remember I played uh demos asabas I
played him in chess and then I quickly
realized
like from his facial expressions that I
should have like stopped playing oh so
it was like it's already set yeah when
it's and then he's like like this is a
good time to like give up right you're
not gonna get to Checkmate where like
there's you know he could see like the
Checkmate is like five or seven moves
away or something this and uh what's the
play
usually you have to resign if you're in
a position or you should through chess
etiquette resign when you're in a
position where
your opponent is definitely going to win
out of respect like if you're a piece
down
um and obviously all top Grand Masters
do that the only people who don't do
that is kids because they're coaches
their coaches always tell them never
resign and they'll be in hopelessly lost
positions playing against like two Rooks
a king and they only have their soul
King but they're still playing on so
that's a position where it's obvious
they can't win because the kids might
make errors yeah so I might as well that
was the interesting thing about I think
uh game six of the previous World
Championship with Magnus was it the one
where he beat nap yeah the first time he
beat him where it was like
he said that I don't know how often you
come across this kind of situation he
said the engines predict a draw yeah but
that doesn't mean that it's going to be
a draw so you play on
hoping that you take a person into that
I mean this is I guess an end game thing
you take them to deep water and they
make a positional mistake or something I
don't I don't know when like he from his
gut knows that this is supposed to be a
draw but he still plays on yeah I mean
that is one where it could theoretically
be a draw but it could be very hard to
defend because it's a hard technique to
know as a human and especially in that
game I know that uh nepo was also in
time pressure which makes it even harder
so in situations like that you should
always continue it's more where an
engine would give you something like
plus 10 or something where it's not just
clearly a win but anybody would know how
to win and that's where you're usually
supposed to resign
so what do you find beautiful about this
game is it the uh
the the attacking chess and just the the
the the asymmetry of it it it's the
asymmetry and it's the fact that this is
the dream for the king's Indian uh where
you're able to get a beautiful attack
and there's also those two really nice
sacrifices where black just continuously
kept putting pressure on white skin to
the point where he was able to win
material and the best part of it is that
the if the attack didn't work out black
would have been completely lost
how often does that happen by the way
like as an attacking player you like how
often do you put yourself in the
position of like
I'm screwed unless this works out on an
online chest more than I should and it's
usually when I sacrifice I know it's
either gonna work or I'm lost
and those are the most fun positions to
play usually but in tournaments if
you're doing a sacrifice you're playing
it with 100 confidence because you're
taking the time to calculate it but yeah
when you have three minutes you don't
have time so you take a whim and you
follow your Intuition or you find out
later or you're very confident it'll
work and you haven't calculated all the
way until the end but you've calculated
to the point where you have enough in
exchange for the stack and you think you
could play that position